du bio produit le plus souvent
localement et en emballage zéro déchet
la base pour ces jeunes entrepreneurs
l'épicerie vrac il l'idée n'a rien de
révolutionnaire mais quand elle est
couplée à un drive ça change tout il
faut des chaînons connaissez pas on s'y
met en même temps qu'on découvre le
drive en fait et ça prend beaucoup moins
de temps les enfants touchent moi
surtout en période de crise vous avez vu
c'est vachement plus facile et puis vont
lâcher si encore en congé maternité mais
quand je reprendrai le travail le drive
cela sera plus adapté comme dans tout
les drives les commandes se font via
internet
mais ici la plupart des produits est
conditionné en arrière boutique pâtes
céréales fromage ou produit ménager le
retour de la consigne façon épicerie
d'antan mais dans des conditions
sanitaires frites on est conditionné en
corner un responsable de la sécurité
sanitaire de nos contenus on travaille
majoritairement mode drive à se faire
que nos clients quand ils arrivent alors
comment d'être déjà prête déjà dans les
bocaux et prête à être emmené donc il
n'ya pas de transvasement dans les
contenants clients à ce moment là ouvert
début juillet le drive a pris ses
marques et avec la rentrée les clients
sont plus en plus nombreux
le concept plaît c'est sûr mais en drive
ou pas le passage au bio est souvent
affaire d'engagement veut rendre l'offre
dite alternative un rapide et pratique
pour qu'elle devienne la base et le
pratique et rapide c'est justement par
le biais de ce format drive mais tout ça
au format épicerie également parce qu'en
fait pour nous c'est important de
recréer un lien avec les produits les
producteurs les consommateurs et même un
temps des changes avec chaque client au
moment du retrait des commandes c'est
sur cette épicerie coopérative se
démarque des drags de des supermarchés
est le coût du tout bio pas forcément
accessible à toutes les familles